figuring out what videos to make can be
overwhelming you know you want to impact
the lives of others but
what videos should you make when you're
just starting on youtube
well we're going to be talking about
that and more in today's
episode my name is heather torres and i
am your host of the think
marketing podcast and if you're new here
welcome
we deliver you a brand new podcast every
single
tuesday and i want to encourage you to
subscribe wherever you're consuming this
content from
and i want to say thank you to all of
those who have been sharing the podcast
with your friends we've seen
some amazing growth here on the podcast
because of you sharing
this content so if you've listened to
the past
episodes or if after this one you got
some value
i just want to encourage you to share it
with a friend who needs it
you could do that by taking a screenshot
and sharing it on instagram and tagging
us there well we are in the middle of a
four
part series this is actually episode
number two of that series
and if you didn't listen to episode one
you're gonna wanna make sure you go back
and listen to that we're talking all
about
the four pillars to creating a high
impact
and a high profit youtube channel we
want you to start
youtube right so make sure you go back
and listen to episode one of this series
which is claiming and mastering your
topic we walked through seven questions
that you should answer
when you get started on youtube and we
shared a little bit about our experience
and
how we stumbled upon and got to this
point here so i hope that episode
encourages you
and today we're going to be diving into
discovering
your audience's problems and ambitions
this is one of my favorite topics to
talk about because it really helps you
to go deeper
in understanding and listening to your
audience now
the topic of this video is what video
ideas should you create
we're gonna tell you exactly what videos
you should be making
for your niche well buckle up and get
ready
and we'll dive into today's conversation
with myself and sean cannell
so we've talked about claiming and
mastering your topic this is actually
one of my favorite topics that we're
talking about today which is
understanding the audience's problems
and ambitions and when you're getting
started on youtube when you
want to uh really impact people
understanding their problems and
ambitions i think is key
and we're going to walk through a couple
questions i have for you today
but number one i love that you said this
sean the creator who understands the
viewer best
wins yeah i think that's uh huge and it
seems simple
but it actually is quite profound um to
the degree
that we understand the viewers what
keeps the viewer up at night
what is the viewer going to what's going
to keep their attention watching
a youtube video what problem do they
want to solve what mindset are they
in when they're going to youtube what
questions are they typing in the youtube
search bar
and also not just what problems do they
want to solve but what ambitions do they
want to
achieve sometimes i may want to fix
a problem with my car but my ambition is
to have a nice car
so that i could attract a partner or so
that i could flex in my car club
like what are my ambitions what do i
aspire to be and to the degree that you
understand the viewer
you will beat your competition for that
person who understands the viewer
less it kind of makes me think about
when you have a friend
that's like man we just get each other
like man she gets me he gets me
and then when you also think about uh
maybe somebody else you know an
acquaintance
that there's like it's just awkward it's
like crickets when you're trying to
connect with them or
you communicate and they respond and
you're like you weren't even just
listening or you clearly don't even see
where i'm coming from sometimes that
happens in like relationships
and like dating if someone's ever speed
dated or gone on like maybe a bad date
the lady she's sitting across from the
guy and he's like i'm just talking on
and on about his accounting job
you know about like algorithms and
different things and she's like
being nice she's smiling but she's like
is he gonna ask about me
is he gonna try to understand my
problems is he gonna try to understand
my ambitions he feels out of
touch he doesn't get me i don't think i
can stay with
him or her because she doesn't
get me think about this in business
think about this in youtube you're like
man the creator's out of touch
the restaurant owner is out of touch
like do they even
care they do they even understand that
like what i'm passionate about or the
experience i'd want to have
and then conversely man if that's dialed
in and you're like man
they just get me i feel at home in this
coffee shop man i feel like this youtube
creator
they also they relate with me they
empathize with me but they also help me
they know where i'm coming from and that
is a huge
key to really succeeding on youtube yeah
what i think is really
key about that too is when you are the
person that understands the viewer
best the production value actually
doesn't matter it's the content value
that really matters and when you can
have someone i know you said in the last
episode
that you help really with youtube but
you help kind of the
the normal everyday guy with youtube and
that is so key because his problems are
totally different than say a filmmaker's
problems or
someone who is wanting to do video for
other productions it's so key on
understanding
his problems and ambitions and i love
that you brought that up
and again the production value isn't as
important as the content value
when your viewer says you get me you
understand where i'm coming from you
understand
why i want to do this and i think you do
that so well when you're talking about
wanting to create an impact in people's
lives or the idea
that uh they want to do youtube to
create a sustainable business we're not
here to be
flashy youtubers we're all about
business and really creating a legacy
for your family so
i love that you said that in the last
episode if you didn't watch that make
sure to go back and listen to the
episode one now number two though
there's a huge mistake that people make
when they're making content and
since this is all about understanding
your audience's problems and ambitions
one of the big mistakes is making
actually what we call
selfish content how what what would you
say
about selfish content versus making
content
that is for them yeah i think that
um this is kind of an interesting point
because a lot of people are losing on
youtube because they're making selfish
content
that sounds extreme it sounds like maybe
accusatory
and i actually don't think people are
doing it knowingly i think that
the name of youtube is youtube and they
think man this channel
is about me it's about my thoughts i
kind of want to just get on and
commentate on current events and
we maybe even see somebody do that or we
see a famous influencer that just shares
his thoughts or her thoughts but the
reality is that if you are thinking
about yourself
first or just sharing your thoughts and
not thinking about the viewer first then
you're probably going to lose
and you're probably not going to break
through the noise and a lot of times
this can it'll be illustrated like this
a video starts and someone's in the
video and they're like
you know hey guys welcome back to my
channel you know i've been gone for a
while and
um this is kind of my life update lately
and my dog got sick and
uh you know fido has had that you know
he's been throwing up on the carpets
i've had to clean the carpet but anyways
i know that uh i haven't been posting
videos lately
here's the thing no one knows you
haven't been posting videos lately do
you even think your subscribers are that
engaged
maybe they are but they probably aren't
and they go on and it takes
three minutes five minutes 10 minutes
where you tell your life story before
you get into the value of the content
what i'm not saying is that it's not
about you at all i'm just asking
do you think about the audience first do
you think about
the viewer experience do you think about
their time is valuable
i want to get right to the point for
them i want to solve their problem
quickly and clearly
i don't want to feel like i'm out of
touch you're watching them you're like
does this person
realize that in today's busy world i
can't listen to
them ramble on for hours and hours so
it's really kind of just like a
self-awareness
as well as a sensitivity back again to
the viewer and really being focused on
solving the audience's problems and
ambitions and i heard you know john
maxwell put it this way
that if you will help as many people as
possible get what they
want in life you will get what you want
in life
so ironically to reach your if you will
selfish goals and i don't mean that in a
negative way just your desires
you're going to reach your desires just
by focusing
first on helping your audience reach
their desires
yeah it reminds me of um i rebuilt an rv
this summer
and it was a huge project i actually
didn't own any tools i bought an rv
i wanted to renovate it and i went to
youtube i was like i can learn how to do
this on youtube
and it was so impactful to me because i
was watching content
that was helping me do what i wanted to
do they were showing me step by step
they were showing me the tools and the
things that they wanted
and what they were ultimately doing we
learned this in business and in
marketing
is they were building no like and trust
with me
so now anytime this creator posts a
video i will watch it
i will watch every single minute of this
creator why
i've built the know like and trust
because they helped me solve a problem
i had no clue how to renovate an rv and
they helped me do it step by step
i bought everything they said to buy
because i trusted them
with the content they were giving me now
they shot this content on their iphone
this wasn't massively you know set up
content this was shot on their iphone
while they're traveling so i think it's
so important that when you
make unselfish content when you're
actually helping
your viewer when you know what their
problems and ambitions are
you're able to make content that will
last forever you're able to make content
that will
help your viewers um solve the problem
and then you become the person
that they always want to go to you carve
yourself out in a market where
of course there's other people
renovating rvs it's a huge trend right
now but i'm focused on that one creator
because they helped me
the most now number three is um we want
to solve problems and ambitions and what
i love about the internet is that all
answers are solved on the internet sean
did you know that
so we actually have three different
places that we recommend going
to figure out what problems and
ambitions are if you're kind of stepping
into the niche online
and you kind of have an idea we've got
some resources and places you can go
to actually find what people are typing
into the search bar so
number one would be um actually doing
keyword research touch a little bit on
what keyword research is and how they
can do it
yeah and keyword research is one of our
favorite things here at think marketing
and we won't go too far deep into it we
have our free class at
thinkmasterclass.com that explains in
depth what keyword research is
but basically keywords are the search
terms and interestingly enough
it's not just what you're typing in
google or youtube but it's even what
you're saying
you know my wife sony and i have been
watching a lot of
television during the pandemic and so we
got an apple
tv i've got the little um you know
microphone on it and i hold that down
and i talk to siri and i'm like
siri play raised by wolves on hbo max
you know
and we watch youtube stuff so i'll say
like siri play
phil defranco on hb uh you know on
youtube
and i'll also start looking in siri
show me a review of the saucony
endorphin speed
shoes because i'm into running and all
these different things so it's what are
people
searching for a key word is saucony
endorphins
uh speed shoes phil defranco is a key
word um
how to get views on youtube it's a key
word a key word might be like the word
diet
but a keyword phrase is usually what
we're talking about best diets for women
over
40. and so you want to do keyword
research and again
there's some tactics there's some tools
there's some things i think think master
class would be the best
place for people to go that's
thinkmasterclass.com and we go more in
depth of how to do keyword research and
connect that to optimizing your youtube
videos for views
yeah and you know i know we do have a
lot of entrepreneurs who already
have established businesses now if
they're stepping into the online space
they're starting their youtube channel a
great way to
actually come up with what are the
problems and ambitions that people are
keyword searching
is to survey their target market this is
critical
if you want to actually get the exact
words that they're talking about so
talk a little bit about surveying um and
some questions you might ask
yeah so um one creator
and author business owner that i respect
michael hyatt does an
annual audience survey
and i'm excited at think media soon
we're going to be doing our
annual audience survey where um
this is i recommend any listener usually
if you have an email list or social
media following because you could
put a link to it anywhere you want you
could use something like surveymonkey or
even just like a free
google docs type of a survey the key is
getting feedback getting the language
getting the emotions and actually
listening to the people who are watching
your content
you know another leader i respect name
andy stan the andy stanley says
do for one which you wish you could do
for all so maybe before you get the
million views
what if you serve the 10 people on your
email list really well and
really help them reach their goals could
it spark word of mouth could it spark
some virality could it spark that by you
helping 10 people or 100 people
reach their problems and ambitions that
that's eventually how you're going to
reach the millions that you aspire to
reach
but how does that happen from really
understanding
your target market and one of the best
ways to do that is to ask
and so i think when we send that out i
mean be looking for that we'll send it
on the email list
and uh and and make sure you're signed
up at think media and whatnot and you'll
just see questions
we're just interested a little bit about
like who are you like if we think we're
talking
typically we notice like the core
audience is like
10 years younger and 10 years older than
35 so like 25 to 45
that then spans all the way down to 13
on youtube up to 65 of people in their
legacy years
but that kind of that core audience is
sort of around our ages you know
interestingly enough but you get
feedback because you might have some
misconceptions wow i didn't realize
there's a certain demo
certain gender could be certain getting
feedback about people's economic
uh um you know things but it also could
be
feedback like what other brands do they
watch who else do you watch
uh where else do you get your
information those can be very powerful
questions
but more than anything even if you
didn't want to ask those type of
questions
it's simply saying what's your biggest
problem right now
what are you challenge what's your
biggest challenge right now
with your niche um what
you know what are you searching for what
and so those types of questions but i
think
the secret is make sure you're on our
email lists right and when you sign up
at like thinkmasterclass.com
you end up like that's you enter with
your name and email
and not only can you watch our free
hour-long youtube training but then
you're on our email list so you'll see
the survey go out and whatnot
and swipe it we we we do what's called
swipe copy
you know we'll gather and we've been
refining this for years so you can
potentially pull some of those questions
off and the one other tip is like
without going that deep
take one question and post it on twitter
take one question and post it on
linkedin
how what is your biggest challenge right
now
with your end taxes see what people post
that could be your video
ideas it could be a nuance of you didn't
even really
think that was the question people were
asking or where they were stuck or the
way they would word it
and so bottom line is commit to
consistently
getting feedback from your current
audience yeah and the last way to be
able to
figure out what problems and ambitions
this was where i started when i was
starting in my home school space
was i just started to read comments i
didn't personally have a youtube channel
yet so i was
inside of groups i was reading other
people's comments i was just
out into where is the target target
audience
living online and how can i read what
they're typing in i know this is
something that you do
religiously here at think media is
reading
the comments of our people yeah and
there's something cool in the back end
of youtube that actually
you can select in your youtube studio um
comments with a question
or you can do a search and actually type
in the word question because a lot of
people will say
i have a question would you recommend
this camera or that camera
and so it could be your comments but the
objection might be
well sean i don't have any comments yet
though like i'm just getting started
which that's okay
like you said read other people's
comments go to study the
other channels in your niche look at the
other content creators that are posting
in your niche or business owners
and what's happening in their comments
the powerful thing is that as these
things grow it could be harder and
harder to stay caught up with this
and that can give you an edge when your
organization grows larger
you actually end up going a little bit
slower to keep everybody on board when
you're
nimble maybe a solopreneur you're like a
speedboat when you're a larger
organization you're like an ocean
lighter
so you might be able to react and find
an insight
in if you will a competitor or a similar
channel and be like
man they that person missed this this
that and that this in the video
and it's inspired this other thing and
you might have a spin-off video idea
inspired by somebody else's comments
that could change everything for you and
really put you on the map and here's
what you know
if they're watching for example personal
finance information
they might be subscribed to dave ramsey
robert kiyosaki
and graham stefan they want to learn
personal finance i personally watch all
those guys
i watch uh other guys as well i watch
random people that i find if they've got
a good title and thumbnail and i give
them a shot
and so you know you're tapping into an
audience even though you might not have
built that audience yet
that you're going to just start serving
that target market
while you're building your community so
good this is why this is one of my
favorite topics i feel like it goes
deeper and deeper and deeper because
i think that your audience will always
have problems you might feel like well i
solved this problem and then there's
another one that pops up because they're
along the same journey
you are so why is this so important
though why is it important to
understand your audience's problems and
ambitions
yeah i think a couple things number one
you're gonna learn their language
you know and uh we we talk about this
all the time at think media
um again is it depth of field or is it
how do i get the blurry background well
the average person's gonna say blurry
background before we hit record on this
episode
we were talking about how many people
really live stream besides use
zoom to do teleconferencing like we
really like
what what are the words people are gonna
say when it comes to the thing that
they're talking about
how are they seeing it and here's the
key they're probably saying it different
than you
once you've learned insider language
once you've learned the insider terms
you're actually distancing yourself from
the people you're trying to help and
reach
i learned this from andy stanley in a
book called deep and wide when it came
to church
and talked about a lot of times a church
that kind of spiritual faith
organization
uses so many ancient biblical terms
that the the day-to-day person's like
okay you just lost me with that term
so it's how do i contextualize my
language one of the best ways to do that
is to actually listen to your audience i
think that's the second tip is listening
is key
you know in marriage we both you've been
married to isaiah
for a long time 15 years 15 years sony
and i just celebrated 15 years is crazy
what do we learn in marriage man
communication is key
if you're not listening to the other
person things are not going to be
getting better and if you are listening
and what do i hear from my wife sonia
honey i don't think you're listening or
i'm watching tv honey are you listening
to me right now or i'm listening to a
podcast
honey are you listening i have noise
cancelling headphones on she's not happy
now
i've been shouting at you from
downstairs are you listening
i think viewers on youtube are maybe
shouting at us hey are you
listening will someone just help and
you'd be surprised
you might feel like there's all kinds of
competition they might not
really be listening and they might not
really be connecting
and there's a lot of people around the
world that are shouting at the top of
their lungs
will someone listen to me will someone
help me and so i think that's the power
of
listening listening to comments
listening to the market listening to
real people
getting in real conversations this stuff
we're talking about heather
will supercharge your youtube content
think marketing podcast if you apply it
yeah and
for me i think you use the example of
the blurry background
and i think when when you are the person
giving the answers to the exact problem
that someone has
i i feel like it makes a greater impact
right it is the listening like you said
but it's the idea
that when you can help someone i don't
know how you feel but i love
i mean i know you feel the same we just
love helping people and so
when we can answer the specific question
we're gonna get into that number four
when you can actually answer the
specific question
you make a greater impact because it's
they're not typing in
depth of field they're typing in blurry
background and they think it's the
camera and you're saying
it's not even the camera it's the lens
they didn't even know and so you
bring light to that situation now number
four is we want to
discover the audience's problems and
ambitions what do we do with that well
we're going to answer specific questions
this is a formula that you
have used here at think uh to really
advance the entire channel so
talk a little bit about what is asq
yeah asq answer specific
questions this is the foundational
strategy that we do
at think media and that i've done and i
want people to be encouraged too because
now
maybe you just join in fact let us know
uh if you leave a review
on itunes or uh leave a comment on the
think marketing
youtube channel if you're watching this
on youtube you know how long have you
been a part of the community did you
just discover us where did you discover
us how did you discover the podcast
um you know we're a team of 12 full-time
people now
in multiple different channels doing
multiple different things but don't get
it confused
i'm a small town kid college dropout
didn't know how to build a business
didn't know how to build a team
it didn't know how to start a youtube
channel didn't know how to make money
online and figured these things out step
by step
brick by brick and just started shooting
videos in my bedroom
really about 10 years ago and
what i did though was from my research
and from investing in myself and from
buying courses and reading books
i did learn that the internet has what's
called search engine optimization
because
people ask the internet questions google
told us that 65
of people google owns youtube go to
youtube
looking for answers to questions so what
should we do
to start answering once we discover our
audience's problems ambitions we want to
start answering our audience's problems
and ambitions and how are we going to
get discovered on youtube
when we actually answer those problems
in the form
of a question and so over the years what
is the best camera for youtube
question mark it's a question and i
would do my best to answer it and it
helped grow my brand when i was just a
solo creator started making money with
affiliate marketing
on my other channel sean cannell was
like i was experimenting
best gift ideas for him
cool christmas gift ideas that's a
question people are looking for
cool christmas gift ideas nowadays i'm
asking questions of the internet
should i get the hyper ice
hyper vice massage gun or should i get
the thera gun
which one's better it's a specific
question that's the versa strategy
that you'll talk about a lot and so it's
asq it's answering specific questions
and what's crazy as i was doing this 10
years ago i was doing it eight years ago
i was you know we've been doing it as a
team for the last five years
now we've got nolan and tony and kyle
and omar they're answering specific
questions
we just continue to do it and of course
our strategy has to evolve that's why we
keep
like our master class updated with uh
the latest changes because
thumbnails titles nuances of breaking
through the noise really matter
but the foundational principles and it's
the same the tactics change but like the
core strategy
asq answer specific questions and i
think
what's so great about that strategy and
it was what gave me
the confidence to start my youtube
channel uh back
five years ago now four years ago um
where you kept saying heather you gotta
start this channel we were on a walk
with our friend benji and you're like
what would you talk about if i asked you
these questions about homeschool
because i didn't know what channel i
wanted to start when i started answering
specific questions i did a video
homeschool versus public school it's now
viral in the homeschool community why
i just answered the question of what
that was and
what that gave me the confidence to do
was to just get base hits
not every video that we make is going to
go viral but what can happen
over time as you continue to make
questions or as you continue to answer
questions
through your videos you'll start to see
that bass hits will turn into home runs
and we
even here at think media we will create
videos knowing they're going to be home
runs
but they just start as base hits it's
answering the questions and
it reminds me of nicole from kidsot help
you know she grabbed her iphone and
created a video about tummy time for
newborns
she didn't know that that was going to
be the answer to someone's question
that now has 2.4 million views on it she
had no idea
but because she was committed to this
process committed to being able to
answer specific questions
and know that her audience has had the
problem of
tummy time for newborns she now has been
able to create an entire business
off of the videos that she's created on
youtube so uh thank you for that
conversation sean i'm excited because in
the next episode
we are now that we answer specific
questions we're going to learn
how do you actually do this youtube
thing right i mean i know that
you're a busy entrepreneur i'm a busy
entrepreneur but like how do you do it
in a few hours per
week and i'm excited because that's one
of the questions that we get here at
think so
that conversation is coming up in the
next episode
well that was the second pillar of
building
your high impact and high profit youtube
channel your action is to go and do
those things that sean said
post that tweet and ask what problem are
you having with
x or get a survey ready so that you can
start
serving your audience i would also say
go and read those comments because
that's going to help you learn how to
answer
those specific questions this was such
an episode filled with so many pieces
that you can take action on so i'd love
to know in the comments
of wherever you're watching let me know
what action are you going to take next
ann
i want to let you know about this
episode and this entire series being
brought to you by our youtube
starter kit maybe getting this starter
kit is your next
step now our youtube starter kit is here
to help you when you're getting started
on youtube and you're feeling
really overwhelmed with all the pieces
like titles and thumbnails and
you know what topics should you be
covering we've put together some of our
best
and most impactful resources here at
think
to help you with your youtube channel
included in this starter kit is our 51
video ideas to jumpstart your channel
we'll help give you
the ideas right away so you can get
started
our 15 best youtube title formulas
for getting views we give you a
basically play-by-play of the titles you
should be using
for your videos and then we have our 51
money-making video ideas these are just
a couple of the things included inside
of this youtube starter kit you can take
action right now
get over 70 off to this valuable kit
when you go to
tubestarterkit.com that's
tubestarterkit.com
go there and you'll see that there's
even more inside of this kit that you
can take action on today
you'll get instant access to it and
start implementing things like
a step-by-step tutorial of how to use
lightroom and photoshop to editing your
videos
and also things like our gear guide so
if you've not
figured out what setup you want for
youtube we've got that in there
and so much more well i want to give you
the comment of the day
we love when you rate and review this
podcast over on apple
itunes you can leave a review and we
will maybe read it here on the podcast
today's comes from seeker bear and
seeker bear says
valuable information great guests and
entertainment
one in all thank you for all the content
on
all platforms you know we started the
think marketing podcast
we didn't want to just bring it to you
in an audio form we know
that some of you like to consume things
on youtube and so we wanted to make this
available for you
on all platforms where you can consume
this that works best for you you consume
it wherever you like to
consume content so if you're out on a
walk with your dog right now if you're
driving in traffic right now
i just want to say thank you for being a
part of our think
community it is so important to us that
you know that we are obsessed
with your success we want you to succeed
on youtube because we know that youtube
could be the vehicle for your
financial freedom for your time freedom
for your family freedom
and so we want to be here as educators
as mentors as teachers to help you along
the journey that we've gone on i want to
thank you so much for listening to this
episode
and remember if you got value out of
this episode we'd love for you to
share it with a friend you can share
this podcast on social media or send it
in a text message or an email to a
friend who you know
needs to get started on youtube next
episode we're going to be diving into
pillar
number three and i'm going to be doing a
conversation where
sean is asking me questions about
running a youtube channel with three
kids
homeschooling running ministry all the
things we want to break down how to make
youtube successful
in only five hours a week that's right
you can do youtube in under
five hours a week and how to stay
consistent and take the difficulty of
actually creating content
out of the equation all that and more is
coming up in the next episode
of the think marketing podcast thanks
for listening and we'll catch you in the
next episode
you